FIFA 19 is nearly here in case you
hadn't heard it adds the Champions
League license to the FIFA franchise for
the first time in a decade unlucky the
PES but some fans have criticized EA for
changing little else about this year's
game than some small tweaks to Ultimate
Team at Gamescom I spoke to Sam Rivera
FIFA's leaked gameplay producer who
confirmed to us that pro clubs has no
new editions except for some new
licenses while career mode has basically
nothing new except some paltry new
additions like the addition of a star
above your club bad if you win the
Champions League but once you get onto
the pitch FIFA 19 is packed full of
small but meaningful tweaks so here are
19 new features that we thought were
worth your attention straight off the
bat EA have attempted to add a little
bit more depth to FIFA shooting this
year with the addition of timed
finishing you can now attempt to hit a
shot even sweeter than before by tapping
circle or B a second time just as your
foot hits the ball get the timing right
and there's a decent chance the ball be
flying into the top corner follow my
example and it will probably end up in
rosette or end up squashing a few days
he's around the corner flag
if you're the sort of FIFA player who
likes to play it from the back then this
one's for you you know when you're
playing next to a friend and you want to
play it to your centre back all right
back from a goal kick but if you move
the stick
you'll make you'll see the camera swing
around and know where you're gonna pass
to now moving the stick from a goal kick
doesn't move the camera so you can
emulate Barcelona and Manchester City T
heart's content
one of the pair's 2018 s best small
improvements was a gray marker above the
currently selected second player when
defending this allows you to know which
second man will press and which player
you'll switch to should you press l1 or
left bumper EA has smartly borrowed the
idea and put it into FIFA 19
[Music]
passing in general feels better this
year but the biggest step forward has
been seen in through passes which feel
much more natural they feel way more
powerful too powerful in fact and I
wouldn't be surprised to see them nerfed
before launch I mean just look at the
stay of these filthy passes
[Applause]
Jordan headed Marnie ei says that 50/50
battles over a loose ball may take into
account many more variables than they
did last year in our playtime these
battles for the possession didn't appear
to have the frustrating unpredictability
of FIFA's past instead 50 50 battles
felt more responsive taking into account
player attributes and user reaction
times for all the wannabe football
managers out there EA has greatly
expanded FIFA's tactical options this
year for example you can now tell your
full bets what kind of runs to make when
on the attack on top of that you can
also tell a central midfielder to cover
the wing or the center of the park quite
why you'd ever want them standing on the
touchline when the ball is in the middle
is beyond me
full disclosure I am colorblind which in
the past has made it quite difficult to
tell which team is which on FIFA's
mini-map thankfully in FIFA 19 1 0 half
triangular icons as opposed to the
standard circular ones
[Applause]
off the pitch game plans are a new
feature that allow you to configure
alternate tactical options before the
match this means you can now have
separate game plans for when you one
kneel down and need to go on the
offensive
pushing for backs up and having more
players throughout the box obviously and
for when you tune it up and want to
protect your lead unfortunately this
means the old presets all-out attack and
part the busts are a thing of the past
staying within the menus you can also
now have greater control over your
team's defensive style that means you
can change the way your team attempt to
reclaim the ball via the following
settings pressure after possession loss
constant pressure drop back balanced and
pressure on heavy touch
and ass has become a common feature in
football games you can now adjust your
team's width and depth in FIFA 19
however you can also adjust the number
of players you send forward for corner
kicks and tweak how many players will
make forward runs in play the champion Z
will of course be seen in the journey
ultimate team and career mode but will
also get its own standalone mode within
that you can set up a custom Champions
League and have it include any team you
like or you can also play a Champions
League branded match with any two teams
in kickoff great news for all the
Arsenal fans out there
and this next point probably got a
little lost in the excitement of getting
the Champions League license but the
Europa League would also be in FIFA 19
great news for all the Arsenal fans out
there
back on the pitch headers now feel far
more satisfying whether it should play a
hanging in the air that little bit
longer when jumping or timing their run
to perfection headers have a dynamism to
them that make them feel much more
powerful than before
[Applause]
in fact player animation across the
board feels way smoother thanks in part
to the active touch system the new
system allows for better first touches
with many different parts of the body
which both looks great and gives you
greater control over the ball chief
among these new animations is a new
faint move which means you can now faint
to go in one direction before touching
the ball off in the opposite direction
and then there's the updated animations
for step overs which appear to be easier
to trigger and a little more powerful
than before one of the most annoying
things about previous FIFA games is that
it was never totally clear whether
in-game tactical options such as forcing
your defense to play an offside trap
were activated once you click the button
you never knew whether it would be
active permanently or if it was just
temporary and whether or not it was
currently active this year there's a
clear toggle so you know when you're
telling a centre-back to join the attack
I mean you should probably be able to
tell from the 6 foot 6 inch lump there
standing on the goal line so if not you
should probably get your eyes checked
a neat little addition within the match
preview screen is the detailed stats
menu effectively an extended score sheet
these exhaustive menus will keep track
of all your play session stats against
your opponent whether it's AI or your
mate sitting next to you maybe you'd
like to play best of five whereas your
mate likes to settle the winner on
aggregate regardless it will be within
these menus that those petty arguments
will be settled look I told you decided
my aggregate is for Champions League
matches will feature these funky looking
banners in the build-up to each match
now I know that's a tiny detail but I am
a sucker for neat little touches like
that
[Music]
last and probably fair to say least is
the clock in stoppage time as the game
enters into its final moments the clock
no longer freezes at ninety minutes
instead continuing on to show you how
much injury time you have left it's not
exactly a grain breaking edition but
it's appreciated all the same
there are 19 new additions and
enhancements that we saw in our time
with FIFA 19 let us know your thoughts
on FIFA 19 good and bad in the comments
section below or you can come and
complain to me on twitter i'm at dare
said and i'll see you next time
you